oh now recently all across California
and LA it has been hotter than Satan's
anus hey I saw a kid cook the pigeon on
the sidewalk mmm squat baby I personally
don't know how you feel about this
ridiculous ass heat but I'm gonna tell
you about hot beer so you already know
what it is do you wanna bet you don't
understand be fat and being in the Sun
it's like wearing a winter coat that you
can never take off when you're skinny
and it's hot yeah you feel it but you
don't feel how's it dipping you handsome
come be on a male and I have underboob
sweat you know what that feels like it
is where it's so hot and moist that you
get like moisture under that flap on
your skin when you sit down check is
humid under my titties like the Amazon
jungle it's different when I sweat and a
skinny person sweats it's two completely
different things when the skinny person
gets sweaty there is a slight
possibility that that [ __ ] might look
sexy on you you just might look like
this when you're fat and you sweat the
probability that you look sexy is about
a month to [ __ ] held up when we sweat
is effective you have a special place
that when you talk to somebody
it looks like your mind and all holy
[ __ ] we're burning last night follow
through with boys what
sweating like a pig you're such a lot
the [ __ ] I would rather it be way too
cold then way too hot because when it's
cold you can stop that [ __ ] what is cold
you can wear a sweater a beating a scarf
a hoodie but when it's hot you
the opposite way but make it do I want
to be buck naked
Justin do other people want to see it
probably not if I don't want to see
myself butt naked I'm pale as hell me
without a shirt I look like the Michelin
tire man to Hershey Kisses and nipples
hey you know what people I don't to
dance why don't I use the AC because I'm
Asian
s but given the fact H people don't use
the air-conditioner cuz that [ __ ] cost
Mike you know what Macy stands for a lot
of cash and that [ __ ] do not have you
know what my whole life I had no idea
what the real purpose of the AC unit was
for because my parents never wanted me
to use it thank you very so messed up
they will tell the child anything if it
saves him some money
Danny what's that for well he said a cos
a bomb he's about so you'll cut yourself
clean you're not trying to say cool
people stay hydrated and let's just pray
that this heat wave is to God daddy oh
and before I sign off to hell with
everybody telling me to drink coconut
water
nature's Gatorade Mon général Korean
booty does make you see the rain you
know what else just like Gatorade
Gatorade it's three big damn you always
cooling by yourself how you thin is like
these stealth nap man with a single
freeze we're seeing you were somewhere
else caught up in the rapture duo's door
do you have the moves like - oh my god
my twins my god I'll sweat it don't put
this in 1080p because you'll see all the
sweat beans